uh so my name is cuba
i work in intel in poland uh
it's 6 a.m in the morning my time so i
will
keep my voice a little bit down because
everybody's asleep
so i'll be talking a bit about machine
learning
and a bit about how how human moves the
mouse and i will show you
a simple uh simple project that i did
for my studies
uh where i tried to implement some
system
for for exactly for moving the mouse
like a human
so i have no previous i i had no
previous experience in
machine learning uh so this is my this
was my first shot
um okay so let's start i will show my
screen
yes so uh this is application this is
not my application
uh the first thing to say um
so you are most of you probably are
familiar with
the recaptcha so in the world of
internet
uh there are many forms in social media
when you set up a social media account
or something like that
and um the administrator of this website
use
uh the mechanism from google code
recaptcha to
basically to tell the bots and humans
apart so to fill the road
bots uh if you are a human and you
click on a field of field this form and
you click
on on the on this form and then you
click on that robot
then it should let you in but if you are
both
this this should prevent you from from
clicking the submit
apart from this clicking mechanism there
are
also an upgraded version of this
recaptcha
which basically
makes an assumption on based on your
activity on the website so if you are
moving how you are moving
your mouse through the website how you
are clicking the buttons
and then it gives you some score uh the
highest score the closer
score to one it means the more you and
the more human you are uh
when the score is less than half it
means that probably you are bought
so this was the motivation for uh for my
project
uh so i i
was reading uh quite a bit about that
and the third one that
underneath uh there's some artificial
intelligence mechanism that's
uh that makes these computations and
these assumptions
so for me it seems natural to use also
ai to
try to trick this mechanism uh
yeah and build some bots to to to move
through a site
without without noticing of this
algorithm
so i was using i was searching for a
tool
uh to that and i decided to use the
tensorflow
for javascript uh some of you may be
familiar with tensorflow
uh feel free to check out this this
amazing website there are
many demos inside you can use ai
directly
directly here you can play pacman with
your
thumbs i'm telling it
where to go okay so i used tensorflow.js
and i
built a simple website that you can see
here
don't worry about this lots of buttons
here uh this was
all only my pr playground
the important thing that you uh that is
for to mention here
you can see the two check boxes on the
left and the right on
on this grey box and
this playground is designed to
i designed it to uh record um
mouse movement while um so so it the
recording starts when i click the
a checkbox and it ends uh when i click
to be
on the b checkbox so let's see how it
works
so when i click a and i move to b
i can replay so you can see
how my hand moved between those check
boxes
so obviously
for a machine if you tell move from
point a
to point b it will be a straight line
in a fraction of a second for human it's
a bit different uh you use a mouse you
have your muscles which are not perfect
this this pattern is obviously not a
straight line uh
and also you you will see some patterns
so i'll collect some
some samples and i will present you
what pattern i found
yeah so here i think it would be the
best example
so what you can see here uh
the the first part is that the points
are quite sparse
so because i'm nonchalantly moving from
point a to point b
because it's fair fair inferior distance
from the point a
and then in the let's say two thirds of
the movement
there's some some
concatenation of concentration of of the
points because i was
probably i was pausing a bit to check
where i am
where am i and how far i'm still i am
still to point b and then
my movement was very very precise
because uh i was moving very very close
to point b
and i wanted to hit exactly the point b
uh
so this is the first pattern this the
concentration of points in
in some places over throughout the
movement and especially at the end
the first pattern that i saw is that
at the first half of the par of the
movement the curvature of this line is
uh very small so it's basically
a straight line but when i was moving
close to point b
the curvature is uh was getting bigger
so these are the two patterns that i
wanted to
see in the results of the ai training
okay so once you have collected the
samples using the tensorflow.js
you can train a model uh
this the tensorflow.js is embedded
exactly in the in the web page
and also there's a small library
tensorflow for visualization
which which creates an additional
overlay for your website which you can
or you can see all the samples that you
that you collected here on the right
the model summary here i use the same
very simple two layer
um two two layer
scheme with sigmoid activation function
of course you can play around with that
and make it a little bit more
complicated so the result will be better
but this is only a simple simple scheme
and here you will see the training
results which obviously should go
as close to zero as possible and
after the results that you have the
results you can
test your your machine learning model
um so this this is a
very small subset of um a very small
subset of
uh of samples so i uh
for the machine learning to uh to be
trained on so i
uh load the pre-trained model uh to show
you
how it worked because it will take too
much time to
collect so many samples
and this is a great feature of about
tensorflow that you can
simply load the pre-trained model and
and weights
so the model is loaded
so this these check boxes are generated
at some random height
and i trained them uh after collecting
uh
very many samples so it was about 200 or
so
and you can see that it is generating
that this pattern generated
actually moves from point a to point b
and if if you look closely you can
clearly see
at least one of the patterns that i
showed you
that the concentration of points near
point b
uh is getting uh
the concentration is getting higher and
higher as we close
as we move closer to point b
yeah and this is this is generated with
machine learning so about
now about the design uh how these
points are calculated so my thought was
that
uh let's say that uh the only knowledge
that i have
uh when i'm starting uh is that my
current point is point a
so i my mouse is uh clicking on
point a and i know the goal the my goal
is point b so this is the the
coordination of
these two points the current and the
goal uh
is the entry to uh to my model
and the output what i want to when i
wants to
uh receiving the output is the next
point in the movement
so when the next point is calculated i
move the current point
to the next point and repeat the whole
process so my current point is now here
i have the goal b and i calculated the
next point
and this works like this um
yeah i can show you um a little bit
more complicated example but the results
are not great
i think it's promising but it requires a
little bit more
work on that so if you have some
comments
let me know on the slack
we can also talk offline after the
meeting
oops
once again my page
yeah so uh these two points are
generated randomly inside the box
and you can obviously see that uh this
the output is not very good uh at least
it's going in the correct direction
uh so my thought my thought is that
the model that i used is very is too
simple
for this kind of problem because it's uh
you know it's not
um in one dimension it's in two
dimensions
and uh what i use is all only a two
layer
um into a neural network so i think
it's if i used probably a different
uh activation function and uh um
maybe more complicated neural network
uh design and the result would be better
uh
i was playing around with with some
activation
functions and i uh and i received
different different results but i don't
want to present you
the intention of this presentation it's
just to give an idea maybe open a
discussion
uh yeah so let me know uh what just
what you think
yeah basically that's all from me let me
know
your questions in slack
you